you're looking at heinz field in
pittsburgh which will be silent today
because the nfl
has postponed the steelers ravens match
up after multiple players tested
positive for the coronavirus
it is the most recent example of how one
of america's annual thanksgiving
traditions
is being disrupted by the pandemic
former steelers head coach bill cower
is cbs sports nfl analyst for today's
texans lions game
on cbs and he joins us now with what to
expect in today's
matchups coach good to see you again
this year
good to see you vlad so let me ask you
thanksgiving to you happy thanksgiving
yeah good to see you my brother so let
me ask you about this matchup uh
baltimore ravens pittsburgh steelers now
you got to wait until sunday
is the nfl doing enough to keep its
players safe
i think they are i think what they're
doing is trying to keep everything as
normal as possible making decisions at
the last minute based on the information
they're given but
you know you're talking about people
testing positive you're talking about
the contact tracing so
it's a very very fluid situation i think
in the nfl but that point i mean to this
point i think that we've gotten all
these games in
is pretty remarkable should the nfl
consider a bubble format
similar to what we saw in the nba
well i think the bubble would have to be
almost within the city's vlad when you
talk about it and as we get closer to
the playoffs maybe that's something to
consider again
you know as you take the in the the data
that we're getting from people and
and uh and and try to keep them isolated
to a certain degree within their
families maybe it's a hotel within each
city so
it's something i think the nfl is
considering and again it's a very fluid
situation so you have to take the
numbers as they come and make the
decisions accordingly
coach you've you've coached your fair
share of thanksgiving a day
games what makes it so special
well michelle i think when you think
about thanksgiving i always go back to
for me
uh football was a big part of it and you
know i remember
the only time i actually was able to
coach on one was back in 1998
on cbs up in detroit it was a game i
really didn't
uh enjoy very much and kind of ruined my
thanksgiving because we lost in overtime
on a coin flip uh
discrepancy i'd say controversy to say
the least but you know when you think
about thanksgiving you think about
football you think about family
and uh and you think about food right
and so i always remember when i was a
kid growing up in pittsburgh the fact
that
you know we always would eat after the
first game we'd have dessert after the
four o'clock game
and then everyone was usually asleep by
seven yeah but how does the pandemic
changing things i mean it's changing it
for the players certainly on the field
but
how is it what's going to be like for
you in the booth
you know i think as we go into the
studio i think what we can do is bring
back some degree of normalcy right i
mean to try to go back to be
very thankful for all the things we have
around us with this pandemic and you
look and
you see the people that are going
through with tougher times than you are
if for that one three-hour period of
time a block of time we can take them
back and to be a fan
to think about your tradition and think
about their teams that's what it's all
about you know you're talking about the
houston texans desean watson
nathan wendy's statistically one of the
best years uh that he's ever had
unfortunately they're not winning games
uh matthew stafford coming off of being
a shout out last week and i think we
look at professional athletes
you're looking at you know what's the
most dangerous and the biggest thing
that motivate them
is pride so i think this game this
afternoon at 12 o'clock that we have
is going to be two teams that are
looking to rebuy they know you're on the
national stage
uh if indeed there are coaching changes
being made this is your resume so
there's a lot to be sa to be uh to be
gained right here
coach coward jericho duncan here i think
you recall that i'm a bills fan
i do drake i do know you're having a
very good year
i'm just saying seven and three top of
the afc east not bad not bad
what are your predictions not bad i
that's not bad and what kind
how about the year josh allen is having
as well you talk about the afc you're
talking about patrick mahomes josh allen
let's not forget about ben
roethlisberger remember he didn't even
play last year
um when you're talking about coming off
the elbow surgery but when you watch the
buffalo bills they're fun to watch
they've been very dynamic they've won
these games they've lost a couple close
ones
but you're looking at josh allen who to
me each and every week
is just gaining confidence more
commander of the offense he got weapons
around him now
stuff on digs and bringing him into the
to the mix so
when you supply a good quarterback i
remember being with ben roethlisberger
in pittsburgh when you get a guy that
you know
what you want to do is give him as many
weapons as you can and i think
sean mcdermott the buffalo bills are
doing that and they're going to be
a team to be reckoned with in the
playoffs all right coach cower we'll be
watching you
today on cbs you're calling the texans
uh detroit lions game thank you so much
my friend happy thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving to you guys the nfl
today begins its thanksgiving day
coverage as i said
of the texans versus the lions today at
noon
eastern 9 a.m pacific right here on cbs